IRE ADERINOKUN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ire Aderinokun,
and I'm a front end developer
based here in Lagos, Nigeria.
I spent most of my
childhood here in Lagos.
I actually went to a primary
school just down the road
from where I live.
Most of the pictures
you find of me
are just with some kind
of weird, angry face.
Like, why am I angry here?
I'm about to eat cake.
I really love being a
front end developer,
particularly working on the
web, because the web is just
such an amazing platform.
You can reach pretty
much anyone, anywhere.
And it's because of
the openness of the web
that I was able to learn how to
be a developer without having
to go and study
computer science.
I also do a lot of
speaking, and I've
spoken at a ton of
events across the world.
But it's also the reason why I
became Nigeria's first and only
female Google Developer Expert.
I actually got to meet
Sundar in person last year.
So he came to Nigeria and
I got to speak with him
about the work I do
as a GDE, and also I
got to show him a
real progressive web
app that I built.
So last year it was my
first time at Google I/O,
and it was a really amazing
but overwhelming experience,
because there's
just so much to do.
And this year, I really
want to take advantage
of being there in person
and meet as many people
as I possibly can.
And also, of course, attend
as many web sessions as I can.
[MUSIC PLAYING]